julia robert's daughter
is all grown up i was just blown away
meet 16 year old hazel motor julia's
daughter with husband danny motor
the teen made her red carpet debut
alongside her cinematographer dad
at the premiere of his new movie flag
day at the ultra chic
cannes film festival and hazel
absolutely brought her
fashion a game oh it was fantastic
check out hazel's pale yellow gown
featuring a collar
and button details she paired her dress
with black patent mary jane pumps and
dainty jewelry
kept her makeup fresh dewy and natural
and for her hair she swept it up into an
effortless ponytail
chic indeed i loved it but danny and
hazel were hardly the only celebrity
family on the cannes red carpet
sean penn who stars in the movie danny
worked on
posed for photos with his daughter dylan
tilda swinton and her daughter honor
were also there check out their fashion
forward ensembles
and this is jude law's 25 year old
daughter iris
she turned heads at a screening for wes
anderson's film
the french dispatch rocking an edgy buzz
cut and ethereal white gown
i'm so thrilled but back to julia and
danny
the couple met on the set of their 2000
movie the mexican
you know you're very sensitive person
for a cold-blooded killer they married
in 2002
and welcomed hazel and her twin brother
phineas in 2004
and a son henry in 2007. the couple is
famously private about their family
but we've seen rare glimpses of the
motor squad on social media
in 2019 dany posted this selfie of hazel
to his instagram page
smiling big with a wide brimmed hat he
sweetly wrote in the caption quote
so lucky this girl is my daughter and
that she takes these awesome selfies on
my phone
fast forward to may danny shared more of
his beautiful family
this time a video of henry skateboarding
doing his
morning commute he also posted this
video of henry
nailing a move up in the air as for
phineas here's a stunning shot of the 16
year old out in the middle of mother
nature
dany asked in the caption what we're all
wondering
quote why must he throw the bottle but
the sweetest image of them all
this photo of the entire fam smiling ear
to ear
dany pays tribute to his wife in the
caption gushing
that pretty mama in the middle we love
you so much
thank you e.t has spoken with julia many
times over the years
in 2013 she opened up about her best
role yet
being a mom what's the best thing about
being a mama i mean what do you enjoy
the most in the fact that you are
staying
home more and able to do that with your
kids i love all of it it is
it's my honor and my privilege above all
things yeah